what's the three greatest Investments
you've made in yourself and would you
recommend those same Investments and
other people or what should they be
doing in their life right now so you
know I will tell you I went to a Harvard
OPM program one time and I spent OPM OPM
is owner president Management program so
if you run a business that does 10
million or more you get to go to it and
it's three years of three weeks living
on campus right I went there but I uh uh
didn't go afterwards for different
reasons but I went there when I spent
that fifty thousand dollars and I was on
campus for three weeks
you spent three weeks with 144 people
from 64 different countries so Watch
What Happens I'm sitting there and at
this point of the game I have no idea
what it is to be a CEO I've gone from
being an employee to a salesperson to a
sales leader to a good manager but I
don't know what it is to be a CEO I have
no idea what it is to be CEO so I sit
next to this guy he becomes my teammate
my partner he uh he owns the Victoria's
Secret of New Zealand and Australia the
reason why I'm laughing is because the
last day
eight of us were chosen to go present a
business opportunity so he keeps telling
me hey Patrick I'm going to kill it just
watch what I'm gonna do I'm going to
scare the hell out of lenetto I think
the lady's name is Linda because she's
the main person that does it watch what
I'm about to do so it goes up on stage
Lewis is a very simple guy I mean good
looking guy but he's not a charismatic
anything just goes up on stage he says
let me tell you why you ought to invest
a million dollars into my new lingerie
line he says here's a PowerPoint here's
the power you see all the sexy women
here you know what I think it's more
important for you to see this face to
face ladies no way brings him in seven
models come in half naked wearing the
lingerie the entire place all the
entrepreneurs are going crazy but the
teachers are furious with them the
ladies are running up takes their jacket
off is trying to cover all these women
it was phenomenal right to see this here
but the point is on Harvard stuff that's
campus right think about it here's the
part five years goes by I'm talking to
you about it that's called marketing
right you remember it I remember it but
when I was sitting next to him I said I
said so listen man I'm trying to I'm
trying to learn how to be a good CEO
what do you suggest about being a good
CEO he says man I got 7 000 employees
and have Seven Seals that report
directly to me I spent three weeks with
this guy telling me stuff that he does
with his shield he's not a motivational
speaker I don't even think he's got a
thousand people following on Instagram
he's worth a couple billion he's not an
influencer but those three weeks of
talking to I was like a kid in a candy
store trying to pull information out of
this guy and it was all technical stuff
it wasn't motivational stuff what time
do you wake up what's your daily routine
none of that stuff it's what do you do
when you're trying to hire a person and
you know you got to give him Equity but
you're afraid to forgive him too much
equity and he leaves early
and you protect yourself that if you
fire him does he still get the other
two-thirds is he still how do you do
this well you set it up this way what do
you do to make sure your attorney that
you have that attorney that you have who
is negotiating with the other attorney
and he doesn't really want to go to
court so behind closed doors they're
settling and he's not really working on
your side he's working on the other side
to kind of speed it up and he how do you
get him to well you got enough to get
another attorney who holds him
accountable I'm like these are the
things that he said to me that you can't
read about in places so you said three
Investments that's one of them uh
vistage was 100 a great investment
because we met once a month uh for three
four years with a man named John Morris
John Morris is a local guy Santa Monica
a guy it'd be grateful you get connected
with him we're sitting on a meeting one
time with John Morris and one of the
entrepreneurs going out of business and
he says uh guys uh I got bad news
because you would start the meeting and
he would say here's my personal life
here's my health here's my marriage
here's my business here's my kids and we
would all Talk Amongst each other and
everybody had to sign in this so you
don't tell your story but one guy gets
up and he says guys I got bad news I'm
about to go out of business why if I
don't get a half a million by this
Friday we're shutting down if I get it
I'll last another year and a half and I
think we'll make it but I'm shutting
down
this is what John does tell me what do
you need for half a million what are you
willing to give up for a half a million
what are you willing to do this he said
give me a second in front of all of us
why are there calls a guy no it calls a
guy who is in his business same industry
says take this call go talk to him terms
boom guy comes back ecstatic by Friday
half a million was in his account wow
this is the kind of guy John Morris is
right so vistage to me was watching
people from different Industries every
month for nine hours for one day nine
hours and everybody would share their
problems it was 1500 bucks a month so
number like that a hundred percent well
worth if you get qualified to go on
because Vistas you have to do is this
like tiger 30 have you ever this thing
called tiger 33 I think it's called it's
kind of like you've got to have 50
million people yeah there's there's
things like that everywhere this is one
of them we got a reveal kind of your
financial plans
yeah there's a lot of that happening
right now and I think it's great I think
it's great if it's by real business
people not social media influencers and
let me explain to what I mean by this
what's social like for example if
somebody wants to learn how to create a
podcast I want to go learn somebody
that's running this like I remember I
think you taught a bunch of people how
to monetize webinars and podcasts like
you were the guy that taught people how
to do the webinars and they you made
people Millions by the way you made a
lot of people a lot of money with what
you were doing with webinars a time that
people didn't think webinars had money
yeah five six seven years ago yeah I
mean at the time that nobody was
thinking about it right so so I've gone
you do webinars why are you doing
webinars oh Lewis taught me how to do
this Lewis Lucia Lewis house oh no [ __ ]
webinars yeah okay so but this is not
webinars this is not this is about these
guys how did you go from bigger strategy
on camera this is this is stuff that you
sit there and you're like wow you guys
are doing how much per year 820 million
dollars how many employees you got 922
how many people on your board seven of
them how do you handle conflicts and
like this is the stuff that you talk
with these guys right at this stage so I
recommend the OPM program I recommend
the vistage program and then I'm a
obsessive reader man I mean I don't know
how many articles and stuff I read so I
would recommend subscribing to when
there's like Business Insider that you
can pay 99 per year pay for it if
there's a Wall Street Journal that you
pay 600 per year pay for it if there are
these handful of stuff that you can get
that's not just a general news if you
spend a thousand two thousand dollars on
these new sites that are sending the
elite articles that's different than the
main ones
don't hesitate pay for it because
everybody's going to talk about the
general stuff but that additional stuff
is written by advanced stuff yeah it's
Advanced so imagine Insider it's The
Insider stuff written by the CFO of
Snapchat that's telling you nine ways to
protect yourself against cyber security
that will be boring to other people but
you're looking and you're saying damn
this was for this was legit so yeah
those those kinds of Investments is what
I would say to you
[Music]